[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Поділля
Велика Яромирка]
Що таке музей?
Це збереження старовини для поколінь.
Моя мета — більше показати історію.
Коли людина знає історію,
вона дивиться на світ інакше.
У 1997 році
пішов на заслужений відпочинок,
пасти коров.
[Серафим Лесько,
засновник музею]
До 2000-го року я робив вітряк.
Сюди дітей багато приходять.
І навіть є відвідувачі з-за кордону.
А це мені приносять.
Одні кажуть, що то є
прадавній годинник.
На цьому терли колись хліб
за допомогою другого камінця,
тисячу років тому.
Борошно робили.
В 1991 році у мене з'явився задум
створити книгу пам'яті
людей яромирських.
Щоб книги не марали,
то я чернетку зробив.
Тут історія в життєописах
мешканців села Великої Яромирки.
За сто років.
Тут історія кожного роду.
Я намагаюся
якнайглибше знайти родовід.
А є такі, що навіть
ім'я по-батькові свого не знають.
Ось, наприклад, фотографія.
Я не знаю цих людей.
[Читає]
«Фотокартка виготовлена 1928 року».
І так усі учні з фотографії
про себе виписують.
Мені бажано, щоб живі виписували,
бо про мертвих можна плести що хочеш.
А коли людина жива,
то тут вже є у книзі.
От: «Діти нашого села,
учні сьомого класу, 1924 року народження».
Їх нема, але одна людина ще жива.
Тож можна вже вивчати.
Одна людина, заміжньою не була.
Отже, з чоловіком не сварилася
і довго прожила.
Я питаю: «Якого року?»
Я, наприклад, 1937 року народження.
Шукаємо 1937 рік.
«Лесько Серафим Олексійович,
191 сторінка».
Ось, Лесько Серафим Олексійович.
Колись відкриють правнуки чи онуки.
От я про себе написав.
Коли приходить онука, праонука, чи прапраонука,
тоді я охоче розповідаю:
«От, дивися, що твій прапрадід написав».
І вони читають.
«Я, Серафим Олексійович Лесько,
народився в селі Велика Яромирка,
15 січня 1937 року
в сім'ї колгоспників.
Батько Олекса оженився
на яромирській дівчині —
Ользі Макарівні Гаврилюк.
Привівши додому Ольгу Макарівну,
вони побудували будинок.
5 січня 1997 року
я організував
відбулися ігри у шахмати
в селі Яромирка.
Я дуже переживав,
чи здійсниться мій задум,
але на змагання прийшли 18 чоловік.
В нашій сім'ї народилося двоє дітей:
Олексій і Володимир.
Обидва сини живуть
зі своїми сім'ями у Сатанові.
Маємо п'ятеро онуків,
які на канікули приїжджають до нас,
допомогають у господарстві.
За своє спільне життя
з Галиною Опанасівною (це моя дружина),
ми побудували новий будинок
і організували все господарство.
Купили легкову автомашину
ВАЗ-2106,
мотоцикл МТ-10.
Це ж не погано жили.
Виховали і дали путівку в життя дітям.
Зараз обоє на пенсії.
Пораємося біля свого господарства.
Свій життєвий шлях
згадав і описав
Лесько Серафим Олексійович».
Ось книга.
Наче дрібниця.
«Життєвий шлях родини Лесько,
села Велика Яромирка,
виражена в фото-світлинах».
От фото-світлини.
Це як фотоальбом,
тільки тут п'ять чи шість поколінь зібрано.
Щоб не подумали, що хвалюся,
в мене книги ще є.
Добре, що ви цікавитеся історією.
«Родовідна книга роду Лесько,
села Велика Яромирка».
Знайшов я
до 1829 року свій рід.
Ось мій родовідний...
Я вже не встигаю
його робити,
онуки народжуються
у Польщі, Москві,
а мені дані треба...
Ось мій родовід.
І пішов, пішов, пішов.
Тут ще треба додати двох маленьких дітей.
Та мені треба дані:
коли родився, скільки важив.
Я конкретно все пишу.
Ось така історія.
Люди, слухайте:
якщо будете робити щось добре для людей,
то воно повертатиметься добром.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Портян]
[Продюсерки
Наталка Панченко, Ольга Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Балка]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]